so and if she had like actually drilled
in and found an easter egg in there just
a little decorated egg we could still do
that or like a Cadbury egg coming out no
that would be a yolk it's gonna do it's
like joke but my my and also eggs
I'm Michael Chabon and I am the
showrunner for season 1 of Star Trek
Picard
I am Akiva Goldsman and I am an
executive producer of that show Star
Trek Picard that he was talking about
today we are here to talk about Easter
eggs that can be found in each and every
episode of Star Trek Picard from this
first season you know we're Jewish right
I feel like it's kind of anthem later no
avi Coleman's done
smiling at me like Anitha Coleman Indian
dear and it's directed I think the
primary thing that defines an easter egg
is that it is hidden there's a
difference between a shout-out or a
callback things that are obvious and
open and deliberate and you're saying oh
he remember this thing well we're
mentioning it now and it's a callback to
that other thing I should have done this
a long time ago you were always welcome
whereas an Easter Egg tends to be
something that has been concealed on
purpose and will not be found or noticed
by someone who isn't looking for it like
an easter egg or enough become mushrooms
an easter egg is not required for the
plot to continue I mean that's the thing
that it's a treat an easter egg is a
surprise and if you find it it makes you
happy but it is it is kind of irrelevant
it's gratuitous don't know if we're
gonna get to cover all of the Easter
eggs because we will forget some we were
also really drunk while making the show
so we will forget even more we're gonna
try I mean there one thing's absolutely
certain we put Easter eggs we did yeah I
mean that was something we did for our
own pleasure yes for the anticipated
pleasure of fans so I mean there are
Easter eggs we're gonna try to remember
where we hid them and I think that's
very classically Easter - there's you go
out a couple days later and that's like
what's that smell oh yeah
[Music]
we actually dog no Easter eggs in the
credits no are their credit Paul yeah
yeah
there would be Easter egg in the poker
playing if the five queens were a
reference to queue yes but they are not
they're not so that's not a nice job but
it could have been good of it some
people thought it was to pretend yeah
maybe there are no Easter eggs in the
show is that gonna wreck this yeah that
had a bunch of Easter eggs there are a
lot of history room of eggs yeah that's
that that is a basket a basket of it
really is not just we the writers but
very much the production designer and
set decorator and all the people
involved in creating the set of the
Starfleet archive viewed that as an
opportunity to hide a bunch of Easter
eggs lunch the big obvious one that's
easiest to see I think is the banner
people caught a happy Captain Picard day
it's a recreation of a prop that was
created for an episode of the next
generation in which the children on
board the enterprise celebrate Captain
Picard day and it was recreated ours is
less shiny is they yeah it is apparently
some people criticized for not being
shiny enough there is a scale model of
the Stargazer
which is cards first its manners command
that was the first ship he ever captain
there's a Klingon bot let I think
actually we're more Klingon weapons but
we could only really see that one
there's cards collected Shakespeare that
we see in a number of episodes that he
keeps in his quarters and refers to
which in a way is a kind of multiple
Easter Egg because in some ways it's
almost less of a reference to Captain
Picard than it is to the actor who
portrays him Sir Patrick Stewart who is
a noted and one of the greatest she
experienced a KERS of his generation one
thing I remember is when Patrick walked
on to that set and it was one of the I
think it was a pretty shot so it was a
big day for him first day back as Picard
and he walked into that archive and it
seemed like it meant a lot to him and he
he just immediately gravitated toward
certain things that
and something personally to him things
that he remembered is it but there are
some other things in the archive there
before you get to the painting there are
super easter eggs we never found yes
that's right they never buried they
never got shown on camera but now I
can't remember what they were so I'm
useless I've been saying that for and
tires but maybe somebody could get in
there with a really really deep freeze
frame kind of thing and do it like kind
of Blade Runner style you know there was
some kind of like certificate a framed
sort of diploma or certificate that was
naming jean-luc Picard something or
other but I I can't remember what it
wasn't
you have a taste for the classic well
that's not really an easter egg it's a
little bit of an inside reference it had
a couple of meanings for us the original
name of Girardi's character was certain
was named after a character in Asimov's
the caves of Steel who was a roboticist
and that would have been that would have
been any general we broke we broke it
and the matzah went in crumbs that good
ground as we were writing that into the
script Patrick then had the idea for the
science fiction long mm-hmm which he
thought would be sort of fun and inside
but that's not really an easter egg it's
a kind of wink-wink nudge-nudge which is
a Monty Python reference Easter yes
about Patrick's own lack of affinity for
science fiction and how funny that would
be coming out of Picard's mouth in a
science fiction show really cared for
science fiction I guess I just didn't
get it
although it rubbed some fans the wrong
way controversy in it for that to have
really been an easter egg that we would
have had it on the shelf behind in the
background and when Patrick went Picard
was stand there you would have seen
iRobot and that would have created an
Easter Egg but the moment we draw
attention to a shine the light on it
yeah yeah yeah and it's just an egg it's
an egg yeah
Easter Egg Easter eggs yeah you know and
I remember in writing the script I know
we had already decided that was gonna be
the location and as I was writing it you
know I wrote in the slug heading Vasquez
rocks in the action line under it I
think I wrote like why bother to hide it
and then the fact that it gets
identified on-screen that way ultimately
it's a kind of multiple Easter egg in
the sense that not only has Vasquez
rocks been used repeatedly within Star
Trek and various Star Trek series to
serve as alien planet but it's been used
continuously than many other TV series
but always as something else it never
got a chance to play itself before at
least I'm aware of so you know it's sort
of a multiple reference not just to the
fact that it has a place in Star Trek
history but also to the place of Vasquez
rocks sort of in TV history or movie
history that it's always somewhere else
and never itself and additionally it is
the the mother hen of all Easter eggs of
the season in that it is the place where
Captain Kirk fought and defeated the
Gorn and no episode passed through our
greedy little trekker Trekkie still
Trekkie to me fingers without Michael
and I trying and failing to get a wink
or a nod to the Gorn into text and on
the screen and we were defeated at every
every turn there are a few little Gorn
references slipped through it we will we
will get - I guess - I think ultimately
originally the script called for and
there was a painting on black velvet of
a Gorn
it's a dayglo Gore by John eaves who is
a storied legendary figure in the
history of Star Trek he's a production
designer and he himself painted these
paintings they're spectacular he did two
of them one of which I have one of it
even now has but it was on the wall
behind so generic if you look at the
cliff now you look behind them you'll
see this sort of hard to explain through
traffic's moving like Romulan letters
kind of shifting across a screen behind
them but hidden underneath that is a
black velvet painting of a Gordon which
is so easter-egg II that it's not even
visible exactly that's one of the ones
that become you come out a week later
and you're like wait that's me yeah
akiva and I have known each other for a
really long time I don't think until we
start working on this series did that
each of us discover that among the many
things we have in common is it just a
rabid love love of the Gorn and so we
did try to squeeze Gorn in everywhere we
possibly could short of actually like
writing a Gorn into the series as a Kiva
says most of them ended up on the
cutting room floor or just never even
made it onto the screen at all I'm
strong it is a dog Gorn it I don't know
why there's this calling Gorn hate out
there see what I did
dog Gordon
it's clever it's you're meant to see it
yeah I think if you're meant to see
something I mean do you need to see that
kind of it's right on the line right oh
it's right on the line it's funny yeah
thank you you know I think one of the
things we were trying to do in creating
the world of the Romulan controlled
severed Borg cube was to try to create a
sense that it's a workplace you know
that it's place people show up and they
get credentialed to work there and they
have work rules and regulations and they
were uniforms and they have badges and
this is a research facility and you know
just trying to think of ways to make it
feel more like a workspace and a
facility just short of having like the
OSHA regulations tacked up on the wall
that was a good way to do it I was funny
engage the card chief contact with a Q
continuum arbiter of succession for the
Klingon Empire savior of Earth from
bargain vision the purpose of it is oh
this guy is storied right and it works
as owed this guy is storage without
specificity like we could have said
famed destroyer of the schlumpy right
he's a big deal he's a big deal and by
adding in these specifics rather than
say new specifics that we could have
created that could have existed in the
ten years between the last time we saw
him on screen and now we gave a separate
set of delights hopefully mm-hmm or
opportunities for criticism to fans
right yeah I think so I mean so maybe
it's not enough you Coleman but it's
like one of the other monsters on the
elite whoops yeah yeah you know what it
is it's like that you know sometimes you
get the egg and you think it's gonna be
solid chocolate but actually it's it's
leaking a kind of semi viscous sweet
really Oh Cadbury egg yeah yeah they
should be a solid
yeah there you go denna
one of the few references to the Gorn to
survive all the way onto the screen in
the first season of Star Trek Picard is
a fleeting glimpse as Rafi is viewing
the data that jarate provided and sure
her eye gets caught by this transmission
from free cloud this transmission has
been encrypted there's a little
encryption signature called Gorn egg and
why this is in fact in my view a easter
egg within an easter egg that as we
press deeper into the labyrinth that was
Star Trek season one there was a
conspiracy against having the Gorn write
that show this Gorn egg as a
representation of the tip of the iceberg
of a conspiracy was also a fractal
representation of the conspiracy against
the born inertia the whole anti Goren
anti Gorn says there's a faction from
the fact that someone would name their
encryption program Gorn egg
I think we can presume something that
might you know at this point maybe
should be considered canon is that Gorn
eggs must be really hard hard like hard
to crack oh it isn't not just an easter
egg it's a cornet yeah add that since
we've added to Cannon you're welcome
can i stir eggs be extra scenario can
they be sound and music yes they could
right I mean you have that I mean now
skipping back to the question of the
opening credits you have a little Eve
occasion right at the end of the credits
sequence musically of the regular life
right yeah from the episode inner light
yeah
[Music]
so mr. Jackson East Jackson East we I
lied
there are Easter eggs and this is
terrible
engage
[Music]
the next-gen theme was not in that be
story no we're here I think it's more
like a deliberate location vocation and
saying to the audience not only is this
an exciting stirring moment but also
maybe maybe it's an easter egg might be
an easter egg borderline yeah yeah maybe
maybe yeah it's right on the edge in
Easter yeah yeah
your line for Easter egg no that again I
think that's the ramen
Joel untrue first we just hear it spoken
and then with the additional gesture
that greeting John true is its cannon
yes just simply that's how Romulans
greetings others this would not be an
easter exactly there are a lot of
Romulans in this season and there are a
lot of run-ins talking to each other we
have in Canon this idea of the universal
translator but the universal translator
well it solves so many storytelling
problems and is why it was invented in
the first place no doubt if your goal is
to allow people to have conversations
that aren't understood by the people who
are standing right there then the
universal translators kind of
counterproductive
we were tried to be careful to show that
when characters were speaking Romulan it
was because there were people present
who didn't understand Romulan and we
were in a location where there is
assumably no universal translator in
operation and therefore we were gonna
need a Romulan language now we really
wanted a real language that was created
by a linguist that have rules and
grammar and so we reached out to a guy
named Trent Pearson he was a big Star
Trek fan it turned out and he just
really went for it and he did something
so I thought so genius
he took the Canon notion that Romulans
are descended from Vulcans essentially
they are sort of the offspring of a kind
of rogue contingent of Vulcans who left
Vulcan a really long time ago and became
Romulans and he went back to Vulcan the
language that has also been created in
Cannon and said well how might that
language have changed and evolved if I
follow the known rules of grammar the
known linguistic rules of how languages
change over time what might that
language the Vulcan language have become
thousands of years later and so the
Romulan language that we have on our
show is a true descendent of the Vulcan
language that we know about it just
cements it really fully with the
established continuity
that's what everyone's know cuz Ryker
says later I'd recognize that a head
tilt
anyway and I think it appears as an
easter egg burst first and anyone who
doesn't know data doesn't know that he
did that it'll just be like why is she
doing that with her head when he shipped
on for the beta quadrant I pulled the
Edison
yeah that's an easter egg absolutely
Harlan Ellison was not only a seminal
science fiction writer in his own right
and a significant influence on all of us
who anyway write or our fans of science
fiction he also authored the city on the
edge of forever which is certainly my
favoritest Star Trek episode from the
original series he exists as someone
whose name is writ large for folks who
love Star Trek on Michael you wrote him
in there because he had Polaroids of you
right oh there's that - yeah there is
that - yeah we don't need to go into but
I think the only thing I would add to
that is starship names have
traditionally been a fertile hiding
place for Easter eggs over the course of
Star Trek and I forget now which series
there's some series where a number of
the starship names that you hear about
our our places in Montana and it's
because somebody responsible for the
show at that year I was from Montana had
some connection there's the Bozeman and
there's some other names like that so
it's a it's it's a fun thing to try to
do it is an Easter Egg more than say
naming a ship after Harlan Ellison the
wellbore class that's actually telling
you something a little more because
raoul wallenberg was a Swedish diplomat
during the Second World War who
personally intervened using his power as
a diplomat as a representative of the
Swedish government to save many hundreds
if not a couple thousand Jews who would
have otherwise been fallen victim to the
Nazi death machine so by naming this
class of rescue ships that is designed
to save people's lives in large numbers
from a huge
struction Starfleet presumably was
deliberately invoking the memory of this
this righteous man and the work that he
did to help people who are in trouble so
it actually has a kind of a storytelling
element to yeah
where's your cortical node buddy there's
an episode where he gives up his
cortical implant is consistent like if
we'd said oh and here's your cortical
implant all the fans of Voyager would
have said he doesn't have a cord oh that
would have been wrong right but but you
we could certainly not have talked about
any cortical in yeah yeah so this sort
of it's gotta be in there somewhere meet
it satisfies the criteria of meaning
nothing yes who don't know anything
about this yes in that sense it's it's
hidden in a way because of that because
it yeah and it's additive for those who
know right I think it's an Eastern ok
yeah yeah that's a matzo yeah
John use an easter egg thanks yeah try
yeah better still would have been to
have Clint Howard serving it yeah that
is a reference to an episode from the
original series called the core
moonlight maneuver in which a very young
Clint a very very I like a little boy
free gentle Ben yeah weird yeah he
serves this some kind of alcohol called
Tron yeah and apparently in reality that
the beverage that they shot was
grapefruit juice and that Clint Howard
he did the taste of grapefruit juice and
so it was a very painful scene for him
it didn't start out as an easter egg it
started out as our wanting to have the
character of the Jaisal be another
member of the same species that we saw
and the court might maneuver right well
that involves so many imponderables
involved casting a kid and using the
voice of an adult which is how they did
Clint Howard and working with kids is
tricky and time-consuming and you have
your hours are really limited and and
then it either a turd in two occasion
oh that's remember which was the feline
species we out unclear that served yeah
maybe yeah and all we got left with
after the infantile alien or the
sentient cat was basically tang yeah
yeah glass and tron yeah it would have
been fun to be able to do either of
those dentist there have been all too
few
Eve occasions in our opinion of the
animated series actually had some quite
interesting fun well-written episodes by
real Star Trek writers who had written
great episodes of the original series
and voiced by the real cast to
enterprise and bears watch it yeah
really centered the fourth season of the
original series not only think it it's
like it had a really shaky canonical
status for a while but I think now we
feel it's good yeah you know would have
been fun with occasion to allude to that
but then you're getting into season
three we had the scripted element of
holographic advertisements you know
freaked out in some ways has aspects of
Switzerland in terms of the sort of
banking regulations of Switzerland
Switzerland's reputation for guarding
the privacy of the people with their
money there it's probably a little
Amsterdam there yes so in terms of like
enforcement of laws that where you're
where if you're not hurting anybody
they're not gonna stop you but they also
have their you know it's very mercantile
is driven by profit and in a way that a
lot of entities now that we see that buy
your information and use and sell your
information and use it to target ads to
you and so it so we had this idea of ads
that would be targeted to each crew
member on the ship as they were being
read and scanned and their histories
were being identified and then they were
being shown ads that would directly
appeal to them according to the
algorithm I didn't get one for a Rios
they take readings of a ship they know
if there's a reading that's a little
often they're suggesting hey take it in
and then we needed a little trademark
character and I just started thinking
about them how you make trademark
characters and how you often will do a
Jolly Green Giant or you know little
cartoon characters that represent
something and I just thought well maybe
I'll just do something like a well-known
alien species from Star Trek the Bolin's
and boolean czar blue we have blue skin
and so then I thought well to make it a
trademark to make it sort of a thing
that people would go like huh that's
funny that's paradoxical make it the red
boolean because there are no red boolean
so
that's how we got the red bouillon I
thought they should all just have porn
what seemed to me what that memory is
everybody and and have a different kind
of I'm really quiet in the writers
really Michael wouldn't do that and I
don't know why not I mean
[Laughter]
that is better egg yeah for sure in the
shot the establishing shot of free cloud
the street there are a few in there
there's the cork bar and there's a mr.
moths hairstyling salon I already
alluded to mr. Mott before there might
even be a couple others in there oh
that's right there's a big holograph
that may literally just be stolen from
episode 10 of season 2 of discovery so
is that an easter egg or is that destroy
stuff sure yeah we can steal Easter egg
yeah and then there's the conversation
in the bar about Rios's fictional
previous assignment mr. pool gopher
ringing off was especially satisfied
with your handling of his trouble with
the breed which also falls into the
category of exposition so for somebody
who hasn't been previously exposed to
Star Trek or in this case Deep Space 9
then it's just oh they gave him a good
cover story right attempt TV Lagoon if
it's not too much bother that is full on
Easter Egg as as Easter Egg II as Easter
eggs get Rafi tells Rios your
personality means too much your clothes
you need to share a little nosh you need
a feather in your hat he's cool he's
collected he doesn't get hot too often
you know what she's trying to say like
you're gonna have to be big you're gonna
be wearing this orange had and the
feather and the green code and you have
to use words like salutation his typical
drink order would be something very um
you know what kind of macho and
straight-up and he thinks I got to go
completely in another direction
so trying to think of tropical drinks
and drinks with lots of layers in them
and swizzle sticks and umbrellas
umbrellas and trying to think well what
is the tropics of Star Trek and I'm
thinking of rice of the the pleasure
planet that many crews had referred to
in various series of Star Trek and went
on memory alpha looking for named
resorts and/or named locales that we've
heard about in Canon on that planet and
10tb Lagoon has been referred to in that
just 10 KB Lagoon who doesn't want to
drink one of them that sounds yummy
doesn't it well I mean if you're into
that sort of pretty much anything with
alcohol sounds yeah
so and so presumably that is a drink
that has been named after the place on
the planet rice of the resort planet
where it was first invented Oh
carrion yeah yeah it's crucial to the
plot but not that not the precise nature
of it right now then not where the tech
was source we could have made up
something like I said the Borg came up
with this thing but yeah we were and
that that's courtesy of Kirsten buyer
who is our comrade and fellow writer and
is our in-house resident expert on all
things canon and in particular all
things Voyager she's I think the
planet's leading expert on Voyager when
we were casting about four ways to get
so G and Picard off that Borg cube and
have him go somewhere else really
quickly without having to get back on
the starship Kirsten was very handily
able to provide us not only with that
technology but with the means by which
it could be where we needed it to be
right
not really an easter egg is it is it it
is not squidgy right squidgy I mean I've
seen some people have wondered whether
it's meant to be a Mugatu and it isn't I
would have a horn if you that's a cool
idea yes we were going in a different
direction with squidgy squidgy with a
road road not taken yes yes coach it was
a bomb but that's another story
yes squidgy was meant to have a much
bigger role in this season but he had
some drug and alcohol problems yeah we
went into rehab yeah we try not to say
that on November yeah okay but anyway
creative differences yeah yeah that's
right but the flawed er lunchbox is a
series of storytelling issues we're like
okay we need her to have all of this
girlhood stuff that she's carrying
around that was also evidence of her
having had a childhood which she didn't
so what would that be and then you know
that natural thought I think is like a
lunchbox at some kind of box or
container that in itself speaks of
childhood pop culture roaming with in
the world of Star Trek that could be on
a lunchbox in talking with our resident
professor of Voyager
Kirsten buyer she reminded me about The
Adventures of flotter which is a holo
program that's watched by the character
Naomi Wildman on that show that's aimed
at kids and so then that's where the
idea came to create a slaughter lunchbox
and give it to Shoji it's an East
Jackson easter egg it doesn't have
anything No
good a little trouble around here lately
with things in d6 in T that is out of
that big alert
so Michael and I are both fans of a
science fiction writer named Larry Niven
who has created a series of books that
are referred to as known space we are
not only fans of his but so too were the
folks who made the aforementioned
animated series so what happened was
they reached out to him they tried to
get him to write an episode and he kept
struggling with it so he came back and I
think Vince named the short stories
based on is the slaver weapon yeah he
essentially ended up taking one of his
short stories which existed in the known
space world that include a race of
aliens called the Kazan which are giant
scary cats really so what happened was
then for one brief and shining moment
known space and Star Trek intersected
which if you were star-crossed science
fiction oh my god 1973 I remember like
the watching I can yeah and I'm in the
living room watching the show and I'm
like whoa that said Larry Niven and then
there's a cousin on Star Trek it was
just it served when Superman and
spider-man had that those should not
yeah shouldn't be but it is yes so
there's always been some debate back and
forth about whether or not that's really
Canon or not and are you really allowed
to do it or not and Michael decided to
take the proverbial cat by the horns so
I reached out to Larry Niven which I
tracked down an email for him and I
wrote him an email and explained what
massive fans both akiva and I were an
are of his work and I inquired about
what you know what was his feeling about
because in without depicting them or
employing them in any kind of
storytelling way would he object if we
just made a passing reference to them as
a way of bringing deep pleasure and
satisfaction to thee you know probably
dozens of there may be people out yeah
maybe maybe a score score about people
out there who retain that pleasure that
came from that moment were those you
know the streams crossed and he
that'd be great he was he be flattered
to be pleased or something so I'm and
this is not any legal set no but there's
not in any copyright sense but in terms
of what Canon is if the animated series
is canon then the COS in our canon and
the COS in and i think we are now we've
now confirmed that with this record
yes and that and that that cheering is
is those two yes you're welcome and John
van sitters yeah that's right yeah he
actually just crammed okay I think it's
a nice day
so castra is a reference to Deanna Troi
his sister who died yeah I try being
Kester's mother so testers named after
her deceased aunt right we do a whole
family tree thing here we're very good
at it no kiss true we can eat in just a
few minutes and fat similarly they have
a son named fat and they presumably
named him after daddy is rhykker
Thaddeus right car number one though is
that number one one that's such an
easter egg who said that forget it it's
too late we asked episode one mmm
too bad that was a good one she was
trying to destabilize the viridian
trucker already present in her system oh
the reading myself sure that's an easter
egg I mean it's cannon it doesn't matter
if you know it it is a callback here's
the thing
I knew when you have a plot question or
a problem or something you need a plot
solution to if you're writing something
set in the real world then you like you
like well they pick up the phone or they
go on the internet or they get in their
car whatever it is you solve the problem
with in the real world context of the
show that is sad and there we're a world
in Star Trek when you have certain kinds
of plot problems you can't turn to the
real world context very often but what
you can't turn to is Canon so then when
you're saying well we want the Romulans
to have tracked jarate in a way that is
long-range very detectable you know how
have other writers solve that problem
before and again Kirsten came up with
this thing that she knew up from Kenan
never
in tracker and which i think is in the
movie the undiscovered country yeah you
know it's funny because I mean like but
in that sense for example is transwarp
an easter egg exactly like i think more
like another one that you guys forgot is
days from the other days good taste
remains is that any sir I think so
because you understand it's a name right
and it doesn't mean anything beyond a
name unless you see in the original
series but it doesn't change the story
by not knowing although it makes it
deeper and there there were a few
subsequent reference yes the iridium
tracker iridium for radium that tracker
not an Easter Egg de strim an easter egg
okay I think okay I think don't you
think I do
the idea there with the holograms on
realtionship is that you get the ship
you buy a package if you want it you get
this package install of emergency
Holograms like the doctor on Voyager
he's a medical hologram or presuming
there are more complete installations
where you might have an emergency
engineering hologram an emergency
tactical hologram you install it and
that default persona includes Holograms
that have different accents so the
engineering hologram quite naturally
quite naturally would have a Scottish
accent what that really is is you know
it's an illusion and I think in Easter
Egg to mr. Scott I guess in the fire for
sure and one could sort of even imagine
that Montgomery Scott having been such a
prominent engineer and having lived for
so long that it was sort of on purpose
that they that's right yes it's a
tribute you know whether let's give this
engineering hologram a Scottish accent
in tribute to the most famous Starfleet
engineer ever right like the emergency
writing hologram might have your beard
exactly exactly
Soraka and existentialism so yeah that's
an easter egg we've already established
by this point that Rios likes to read
philosophy and he likes to read
existentialist philosophy
then you know in terms of like when it
came time to write books to be on the
shelves in his quarters it seemed like a
fun idea like what if there somebody had
looked at the philosophy of serac the
greatest vulcan philosopher the inventor
of the entire vulcan way of life that's
centered around logic and looked at his
philosophy in the light of
existentialism i don't know how much you
can see if you freeze frame it but the
author of the book the name that we see
is actually one of the pseudonyms used
by Soren Kierkegaard for some of his
stood on this work so it all kind of we
had Wonder Boys up there but the author
wanted so much money oh yeah I mean I'm
entitled it's just not okay Marta botany
days is a character who appears in the
episode tapestry of Star Trek The Next
Generation which is an episode in which
Q interferes in the timeline allows the
card to go back into his own past and we
see Picard in his Starfleet Academy days
with his cronies his two best friends
that he hangs around with and one of
them is a woman a young you know cadet
soon to become a Starfleet officer whose
name is Martha botanist isn't fine
really Martha I'm fine
that's in these days right to say so
then what we learn is that Martha botany
days went on to be the captain of a
starship
who's first officer is the van der Meer
who then became real captain so she's
kind of like real says Grand Captain
rough you will she was a legend to the
old man
my old man captain banner man that's a
nice director because we could have used
any name that's right or a no name yeah
and we put that in there just to be fun
people who know so yeah
I found this an old school medical
tricorder Easter Egg I mean they didn't
have to be old ones right they could
have been just like up-to-date no those
are there's a way of characterizing
Rios's yes he doesn't have a brand new
emergency battery-operated medkit he has
a he has an old one I feel like it is a
nice prop that sort of suggests that the
universe is deeper that not everybody
has the newest thing and I think it
feels that way feels a little lower tech
but maybe for a TNG fan you see it I
mean then combat yeah the combat in the
box that yeah right so they missed that
war by the way when he says Ryker
LaForge and when he lists there are
those Easter Egg yeah you know so if
we're directly referencing TNG I don't
know it's a good question so good we
don't know yeah you let us yeah yeah you
tell us there are sources of legacy
props out there both on the hands of
collectors and in to some degree in the
hands of Paramount Pictures Garrett Lee
here yes so I don't remember if he found
our props guy Jeff if he found those or
if he made them I don't remember but I
know it was a fun thing for him too did
you
I'm seeing if history plays out the same
way now you called her The Guardian got
a killer know who's you're in front of
that car yes oh you broke it oh no see
break I say missing oh oh that happens
salt shaker yeah we might run into him
angry Reptoids out there
angry rep delight is that I mean are we
talking about corn yeah again I guess
that's the only other thing sadly that's
I mean when if you could see yeah I mean
all season a Picard our view of it elite
with horn literally everywhere you turn
the Gorn the Gorn hegemony as a sort of
umbrella of all Picard it was gonna be
awesome and all that's left is angry
reptile I have reference to angry
reptile
yeah why do they want us to be afraid of
the Gordon why exactly that's right he
asked who's that it's a Ted sturgeon
story right where they make the dolls to
desensitize everybody like a lien
exactly huh huh
[Music]
that's an easter egg
Vulcans martial art yeah sort of a
Vulcan Taichi kind of martial art that's
for sure
an Easter egg in there there are some
other we skipped over there some other
Vulcan Easter eggs on on Commodore OHS
desk she's sitting behind her desk and
she has Vulcan sacred object on her desk
he's got that shakey Bell thing from a
lifetime you can write on the shelf
right background this Vulcan martial art
is part of a sweet sweet references have
it used to evoke an Easter eggs and show
you in the power hierarchy where the
Vulcans live in relation to the Gorn
right oh look another Vulcan reference
isn't a proliferation of Vulcan a
virtual cornucopia of Vulcan references
fun but one Gorn reference one I know
it's sad the hashtag sad hashtag is sad
she plays the theorem beautifully
there's a lot of cannon around Vulcan
and Vulcan practices and serac if you're
looking for something to make an easter
egg out of Klingon and vulcanize they
are probably the two greatest sources of
non-human Star Trek yeah yeah I mean the
cultures have been articulated out is
make it so an easter egg it is yeah and
and it's not said by him him so does
that make it an easter egg I think so
I'd like it to be an easter egg let's
demon it easy I think it is an exciting
news direct yeah okay if he said it not
so much so much but once because she
says it yeah I think so
make itself so they're eggs in the show
basket better tasty I think we got him I
think we got him off this is what that
bum does remember oh and sitting on the
edge of forever and I see and they cut
out on WPIX oh it's an accidental self
favoring yeah yeah it's just seen that
some people didn't see till they were
older and so the show's uncut mm-hmm I
felt so bad but I I know me too
it's just trying to get some wine Easter
eggs are fun to hide and hopefully they
are fun to find yes and so I think we
plan to keep hiding them and may all
your offic omens be found may your
grandpa give you a big silver dollar may
your star check dreams be colorful and
made of chocolate and Hollow no no for
the egg is hollow for the touch this guy
that was a good yolk thank you live long
and prosper
thanks guys
[Music]